and then February 2020 bam that's when
it went and like I said it was just a
bit
the world is very very weird right now
but you know what's the weirdest thing
what the trends to be it has been great
here for simulation Theory well excuse
me sorry uh at this point it looks more
like we are all NPCs and someone is
screwing with the settings for a laugh
quite a weird year isn't it this is the
thing but when we look back on it these
years are so weird weird like most of
our lives were not like this were they
no
it's like we've gone into them they make
[__] nuclear war right Biden trump it
just at the moment it's been a [__]
crazy time man yeah
and the pandemic is like a once in a
hundred years occurrence like think
about like can you really give a [__]
about politics before no like I didn't
care about politics 10 years ago no one
did I really didn't most people didn't I
I used to watch politics but as
entertainment yeah like I'd watch John
Prescott [__] Spa with William Hague
in the House of Commons yeah I'm a nerd
but that's what I do and it was
entertaining but you didn't feel like
everything [__]
do you know what I mean like if they
make the you know if we make the wrong
decision suddenly like thousands of
people are gonna die it's like oh John
Prescott punish someone and he's fat
they were the good days they were [__]
it just makes you realize like how lucky
were we to live through the 90s and
essentially pre-20
like 2007 right the way before the crash
that was such a golden time oh financial
crisis once in 100 years yeah
of that nature of that scale yeah right
bigger than the Great Depression all
within that
you know
that that was another big one yeah and
the thing is it's just getting more
weird do you think it's going to get
more weird yes Anton can we run up all
things do you guys think the world is
going to get more or less weird over the
next five years more or less weird over
the next five years Anton's gonna run a
poll because we want to know
is the world going to get more weird
because right now Francis I'm not going
to lie to you mate
I'd be very comfortable with a bit of
stability yeah you know what I mean I
think like I wouldn't mind if things
settle down a little bit I'm just you
know how weird it's it's weird man the
world is very very weird right now but
you know what's the weirdest thing what
the trans debate in which we are remind
you according to people on Twitter we
are now part of the transmitter yeah so
carry on mate but what gender were you
identifying as today I mean at a very
basic level the idea that if you chop
your dick off or if you don't drop your
dick off sorry I I didn't mean to be
transphobic there yeah right if you say
that you are something you automatically
are that thing yeah that is the most
insane idea can you imagine you go back
40 years yeah and you say to someone you
know what
I think I'm not actually 40.
I'm pointy
Abraham Lincoln came back from the dead
yeah and he said what is one of the top
button or contentious issues of your
Society we're trying to decide what a
woman has made
and he's going like what have you done
with the world in the last 200 years
well you were meant to be improving it
like you've got [__] planes that fly
yeah and cars yeah and and [__]
electricity and Railways and and
everything and you're now arguing about
something human beings have understood
for [__] 5 000 years or probably
animals understood from the very
beginning do you think foxes are walking
around going I'm not sure about that one
more
yeah they cut they know you know what I
mean yeah from brexit and it's and it
started to go weirder and weirder and
weirder after brexit
and then March 2020 or whenever it was
February 2020. bam that's when it went
and like I said it was just a bit of flu
turned out a lot more serious than that
and then
do you remember just sitting there well
like the first day of lockdown and just
thinking
I can't believe this is reality now like
that was weird man
and like [__] the Boris Johnson on TV
and you're like from once in your life
you're actually listening to him yeah
going like oh yeah he's talking yeah
what's he said you know what I mean and
caring just like giving a [__] yeah and
like journalists are there like [__]
[__] their hands are shaking they're
like
wondering if they're all going to come
out of that room my life because they're
just sharing it
and then the masks yeah that was a weird
well yeah because I mean you're not
allowed to say this on YouTube but
questionable efficacy yeah you know what
I mean hmm
and
and everyone just I was just round about
masks yeah
which I can't say this on YouTube but
survey Mac says the weirdness started on
9 11. I mean that was pretty [__]
weird as well
Mike that was that day was mental yeah I
mean it was mental in many ways but it
was mental for me because I was in
Russia yeah and loads of the people
around me were going good
yeah that's that's it but that is how
people think yeah absolutely in many
countries yeah
Darius Hutchinson
bad day at work FF can have a Gammon cam
please